you see the met gala
yes all the servants are wearing masks
and all the elites aren't yep the
funniest thing possible so a lot of
people are ragging on aoc because she
had this this dress saying tax the rich
at a 30 000 event but i'll tell you what
the funniest thing i saw was
the video of her leaving the event where
everyone's cheering and screaming and
she's waving as a staff member is
carrying her dress from behind for her
while wearing a mask and i'm like
nothing says
cyber nightmare dystopia like the
leftist wearing a a fancy tax the rich
dress at a 35 000 per ticket event as
everyone celebrates and cheers for her
and her masked servant carries her dress
for her on the way out
amazing the thing is dude this has been
happening all the way remember gavin
newsom and his french laundry dinner you
had barack obama's birthday party
recently you've had these governors and
mayors going on vacations and holidays
in the uk we've there have been the
scandals there too
and
here's the problem man
pointing out hypocrisy
is only effective on
people who actually have principles
or scribbles right right so
if if i do something that's deeply
hypocritical and someone points it out
i have to check myself right because i
have principles i'm like oh you're right
you know like i was i'm not practicing
what i preach here right i i just my
wrong but
open hip-hop there's no greater flex of
power and authoritarianism than open
hypocrisy and we know this right uh last
year i went to uh romania for a couple
months and i was in bucharest where you
have the second a lot of people don't
know the second biggest
building in the world after the pentagon
is the presidential palace really
yes built by nikolai ceausescu wow their
last communist dictator so the building
i believe was finished in 91 i think he
was killed in 89 so he never lived to
see the completion
this built if you go inside this the
opulence the decadence keep in mind this
is all happening built during the
communist era and you've got all the
communist buildings around he displaced
over 20 i believe over 20 000 citizens
to build this building so he demolished
20 000 the homes of 20 000 people to
create this monstrosity in the center of
bucharest which he never even lived to
see but there's gold on the ceilings
there's over a thousand rooms there's
six floors and when you see the building
keep in mind there's another six floors
underground
wow right the building is so heavy that
it drops a couple centimeters what's it
called every year the presidential
palace in bucharest
it's gigantic i believe it's the second
biggest building after the pentagon in
terms i guess in terms of overall floor
space
this thing is
it's it's insane what do they have what
does it do now what do they use it for
uh they use it a little bit for media
they do use it for some government
activities uh you can take tours of it
but a lot of it i think is just
it it's over a thousand rooms i mean you
that's the size of this place
is unreal you walk in one room and it's
like a
it's like a football field i just
watched huge the video of chachesco
getting executed like uh three weeks ago
or four years he and his wife and i mean
they were like up into the moment up up
against the wall and the woman was like
still like you're the problem you're
wrong and they're wearing their nice
clothes yeah it was on christmas day i
think 1989 televised yeah yeah
and i mean
look we know this you know that under
communism the rule
the rulers are uh
the rulers do okay
the rulers are very are very wealthy and
uh they're living in luxury and yet
everyone else is starving and living in
squad so you think chanchesko was like a
prime example of a hypocrite
obviously i mean i i think as far as i'm
aware all the communist leaders were
right i mean they were living lives of
luxury
and
telling everyone else that you know they
all need to be equal and have their
rations
and uh live in squalor and live in
famine but they were convincing
themselves that they needed the things
that they that they were getting yeah i
mean so it's it's the same mentality
right
the same has happened i mean moving away
from communism just look at
dictatorships right when you've had
dictatorships whether in parts of africa
or in the middle east or in south
america
the people at the top are
bawling they're 100 million billionaires
and meanwhile people are just living in
absolute squalor you got something to
say four million square feet
930 000 square feet
how many floors was it again
underground i want to say it's about 12
floors maybe yeah it's some footprint
that's a massive foot huge it takes an
hour to walk around
it takes an hour
to walk around wow the um not not just
like the perimeter that's bigger than my
college campus it's about the same size
it's huge it's cube it's volume is 2.5
million cubic meters
holy cow it weighs 4 billion
billion pounds 4.10 million tons we
often think about the biggest building
vertically yeah yeah no but this is it's
girthy yeah yeah
if you ever go to if you ever go to
bucharest like oh i'm going for sure
it's worth it it's worth checking this
place out um and there's even tunnels
there's tunnels that go from there to
apparently the tunnels under be
underneath are so big you can drive a
tank through them so they say it's uh
the building the palace is worth 4
billion euro making it the most
expensive administrative building in the
world the cost of heating electricity
and lighting alone exceeds six million
dollars per year
comparable to the total cost of powering
a medium-sized city
amazing
so to your point
getting to openly flaunt the rules
that's that's what this is all about
that's a power flex i mean
what's a greater flex of power than open
hypocrisy right telling people one thing
and you're openly doing another i saw
this photo there's an article in the
spectator it says coveted rules are for
the serfs not for the celebrities it's
true and it's a picture of the kamalaris
step daughter and some other actress or
whatever
and i'm just like bro it's the capital
city from the hunger games and that's
the one thing i hate the most more than
anything probably having grown up in the
south side of chicago
seeing all of the ultra well-off
hoity-toity people and the people i knew
from the suburbs who had good families
and came from wealth and i'm just like i
don't care if you're rich i don't care
if you got nice clothes i care if you
treat other people with respect seeing
people mistreat waiting staff seeing
them mistreat janitors seeing these the
staff at this event all being forced to
wear masks while they flaunt their
wealth with their ridiculous costumes
i'm like yo
these are the worst people it is it's
the same reason why why
woko haram or so
these woke people they're so
insufferable because they'll go on a
rant about you know white supremacy and
being anti-racist and whatever
and then oh a black person disagrees
with them and they're the ones you know
calling them racial slurs or they're the
ones literally
discriminate yeah i've experienced it
right they're the ones literally
discriminating against people based on
race a few months ago what was a big
conversation here in the usa what was it
was that was racist voter id yes
okay
which is the least vaccinated group in
the usa in terms of demographics is it
black people it's black people right
less than less than half the black
people in new york city i believe have
taken the shots okay and now the same
people who are saying that voter ideas
races are now pushing for vaccine
passports no no it's vast id you need
an actual government yeah and you need
an id as well right so you need the you
need the proof of vaccination and you
need an id
and you know that very
disproportionately that's gonna you
you've affected effectively banned black
people most black people from new york
city
from restaurants from gyms or whatever
and this is the same people who less
than a year ago are talking about voter
id being racist yo they're doing it
right now yeah you know right now you've
got the republicans with the they just
passed the voter bill in texas which
included a voter id for mail-in voting
and they're like it's racist and so i
tweeted vaxxer id as racist yeah now
i'll tell you a lot of people were like
oh you're so dumb and i'm like bro what
i'm not talking about vaccine passports
i'm talking about vaxxer id vaxxer ideas
where in new york city to enter a
building you need a physical state
issued id with your picture on it
you also need proof of vaccination but
they're separate
so how are you going to sit there and be
like voter id's race i'm like i agree
vax or id is racist too and they're like
shut your mouth this is the thing i mean
come on going to a thousand dollar
ticketed event wearing a
a dressing tax the rich like
i mean
this is the thing but the hypocrisy
almost
to someone like that it doesn't it
doesn't even matter because they've got
their legions of psychopaths who no
matter what they do and all this open
hypocrisy they're still like yeah this
is great yes slay whatever and it's just
like this is that's why i just can't
take these people seriously there's
there you know i look at what when i
first saw what aoc did i didn't
immediately jump on the like oh
everyone's slamming her for going to the
met i'm like
look i got invited to the clinton gala
sure uh
and it was a black tie affair and i said
i ain't going to wear a black tie i'm
going to wear a a sweater and a beanie
and they said you can't comment so
they're not coming yeah and so if they
said i could i'd be like i'm showing up
to this place with all these rich people
and i'm going to wear my normal clothes
i got no problem and so you know when i
see aoc she's like i'm going to show up
and i'm gonna wear text the rich i'm
like
to a certain extent i would find that
actually acceptable as a good form of
protest to show up and be like in your
faces the problem is she wasn't there
protesting no she was there enjoying her
meal celebrating and smiling with
celebrities waving to everybody and she
was accepting a bribe yeah i'm not going
to mince words aoc took a bribe it was a
35 000 ticket now how do they get around
it it's a charity event of course so
there's no real value except us plebs
can't well i shouldn't say that it's not
fair but regular people can't get in i'm
not going to sit here and pretend that
i'm some like poor person who couldn't
afford to go no the reality is i still
think the
elitism is a problem and yes even if i
am well off i'm still rather lefty on a
lot of these issues and i am disgusted
by the hypocrisy of aoc because she is a
faux leftist she doesn't actually care
about elitism she wants to celebrate
with these people she wants to be one of
them she wants to be with them how dare
she have that man carry her dress in the
mask that sickens me yeah don't come to
me and pretend like she was doing any
activism no that was her excuse to be
like well i was protesting no you
weren't show up pull pull the the cloth
off the table knock over some drinks
give them the finger and say i don't
care for your stupid garbage events you
don't care about any of these people
look what you're doing to all the staff
and making them do well you don't wear
masks you're hypocrites no she didn't
protest she enjoyed her meal and she
left and i think people also need to
know that there's a difference between
being an elite and being an elitist
right you can have people who are
elitists and they're not elite they're
not part of that class and you can have
people who are in the elite class
they're they're worth 100 million plus
they're billionaires but they're not
elitists right so rogan perfect example
great example he's not an elitist right
he's an elite absolutely by by any sort
of measure he'd be considered an elite
but he's not an elitist on a bigger
level i would actually say that people
like trump for that yep right donald
trump is an elite he's a
multi-billionaire right he's not living
like i said but he's not an elitist who
holds his nose and he sees these people
in middle america and people in the
working class and he's just like
you know insulting the i mean
don lemon is an elitist yep right he's
not as elitist trump but he's an elitist
right he will look down
at an insult even on tv
half of the american population oh yeah
perhaps more right and and that's why
people like that are so insufferable
because it's not the fact that oh you've
got money or you're successful it's like
no that's cool but you can have money
and be successful and not look down
on
humanity in general we need people like
that those founding fathers are like
that too yeah the democratic party is
the party of globo gym
you know globo gym
yeah
we're better than you and we know it
yeah that's that's what i think of when
i see them now don't get me wrong the
republican party used to be the same
thing until trump kicked the door in and
said i'm having a well done steak with
ketchup
so that's actually such a good example
yeah it really is it's the perfect
example and and trump played the media
so well because they made fun of him for
doing it yeah and meanwhile regular
middle americans eating their you know
garbage dollar steaks from the savon are
like why is how i like my steak
trump trump was trying to be a man of
the people he was trying to say to them
you know look i'll be like it's a common
political tactic mind you
but you look at what the democrats
they've always tried to be the the party
of limousine liberals
meanwhile they claim republicans you
know they they support cutting taxes for
the billionaires because they think
they'll be rich but they're wrong and
it's like bro you do the exact same
thing you're sitting here with these
celebrities going to the met gala where
they have no no no covet rules and you
do and you're you're licking their boots
maybe if you took the boot out of your
mouth you'd be able to smell and see
what was going on but you're smelling
all their stanky feet so what can i say
no doubt and it's the same reason why
people find so much of hollywood and
celebrities just insufferable it's not
because they're rich or because they're
famous or they're successful
kudos for that that's awesome it's when
their
sneering and looking down at and
literally openly just
mocking
huge swathes of people oftentimes people
who have actually
put them in that position
of
success right i mean it's not that oh
the only people who
watch movies are
uh you know wealthy elites it's like nah
like everyone watches movies everyone
plays video games different people read
comic books whatever so when you have
that audience and you're openly
hostile towards them it really rubs
people the wrong way and i don't again i
don't know if maybe they do some of that
unintentionally or if it's intentional
but i think that's part of what led to
the backlash i think in 2016 both in the
uk with the brexit situation and with
trump i think a lot of that was
cultural
backlash it wasn't purely politics
politics was a part of it the economy
was a part of it but it's also just
people like look i'm tired of i'm tired
of you guys like just
talking to us like that and treating us
like that so you know what
this guy ain't perfect or this thing
ain't perfect but
we're we're gonna go for that you know
i've been i've been thinking more and
more about um
i've always kind of felt this way like i
mentioned the the elites the met gala
the capital city the hunger games and
just like the snooty behavior i've known
people my whole life who just have this
attitude of i'm better than you and i
know it i've seen them all around and i
can't stand it i despise those people
and so when i see a lot of the
high-profile people who are supposedly
opposed to that who have massive wealth
and then use that wealth to buy
themselves stuff infinity pools and
condos and fancy stuff i'm just like
why like you know like with his cars
because he wants it it's his fu money do
whatever you want with your money that's
true i completely agree with that i just
wonder why it is joe doesn't just find
somebody who's like
advocacy maybe maybe he is i don't wanna
i don't wanna you know throw anything at
anybody who's you know be at aoc or
otherwise who's donating and doing
cherry behind the scenes you know hassan
[ __ ] bought uh what was like a was a
three million million three million
dollar house and they were like why
aren't you giving a chair and he's like
i am i just don't publicize i'm like
that's fair because i give a lot too
but i i just look at to a lot of these
people
hassan included you know left or right i
don't care if you're making millions of
dollars why aren't you building stuff
with it yeah so like we have this you
know we have the vlog and we have the
million dollar skate mansion we call it
but like we've we've reached capacity
basically in this house with how many
people we're staffing and hiring
bringing people in and just being like
do your thing and make good stuff and
we're going to try and build something
and and now we're looking at buying a
venue because the goal is not to have
money to buy
load up a garage full of sports cars or
to get myself an infinity pool and a
luxury a condo in dc or anything like
that
i'm like
you know i want to just hire people it's
not super easy to do but my point is i
look at a lot of these ultra rich people
buying yachts and stuff i guess i guess
i get it when you have so much money
it's like what do you do anyway but it
really is hard to manage i just wonder
why it is that there's so many people
who are active in politics who are
extremely well-off
who don't do anything beyond their
shtick
because it comes down to their
principles and values you know everyone
has a different different principles and
a different value system and i think
that when it comes to money and power
i believe that those are primarily
amplifiers right they're enablers so if
you are
you know if you are if you're naturally
a fairly
genuinely generous person who cares
about like helping others and building
and helping up right and you come into a
lot of money or power
that will be amplified and you will then
have the means
to
help oh cool i can help even more people
now i can build even more now whatever
right i think that's your that's your
position but if you take someone it's an
amplifier right if you take someone
who's a little bit of an alcoholic or a
little bit of a drug addict and you give
them like millions of dollars what's
going to happen right they become a
major alcoholic they become a major drug
addict if you take someone who's a
little bit got authoritarian tendencies
and likes to tell them tell people what
to do and bully people and whatever
you know if they're if they have not a
lot of money power and status then
they're kept in check because they
they're not they don't have the capacity
to do a lot of harm right so look at the
look at crazy dictators whether you're
looking at the saddam hussein's or the
gaddafi's or the idi means whatever
right those are people who then you give
them essentially limitless power and
funds
and they can enact all of their crazy
psychopathic
stuff right
hitler isn't the only
hitler wasn't the only hitler out there
it's just he was the one who actually
had the
power and capacity to do and this is
quite a dark thought but there are
millions of people who if you gave them
that same unchecked power
they would also commit genocide
which which which is which is scary but
there are there that those people exist
they exist but they don't have the power
and the capacity to go about and do that
and so
it's a little bit of a sobering thought
but i just think that's reality i think
i i i have you know two two thoughts on
this sure one is like i don't understand
why people who have money don't do more
cool stuff you end up seeing typically
it's an issue it's a it's something of
the left mackenzie bezos gets billions
and what does she do she just dumps
billions of dollars into critical race
theory and social justice
and then you know you uh you have some
right-wing personalities and
high-profile families that are wealthy
and that fund a lot of stuff the mercers
the the koch brothers and things like
that i don't know what the kochs are
doing as of late but i think it's just
now isn't it
oh yeah yeah and so my point is there
are a lot of very wealthy people
who just choose to have whatever they
want and there's a tendency that we see
on the left hardcore political activism
tom steyer michael bloomberg george
soros etc mackenzie bezos flooding the
left with money giving resources all
these people to support this stuff
and i don't think you have nearly as
much on the right and the same is true
for the culture war there are a lot of
personalities who have moderately sized
podcasts and youtube channels that are
making hundreds of thousands if not
millions plus per year and they just put
in their pocket put in the bank buy
stuff for themselves and their family
and they don't invest meanwhile
you have left-wing activist
organizations that you know the way to
describe it is
you've got a game of tug-of-war where
one side is pulling with all their might
the left and the right is just trying to
stay where they are if you're not
pulling back and you're just trying to
stand you're going to get knocked down
you're going to get pulled down yeah so
i just i've been thinking about this for
a while i'm like
if you're going to go out
on youtube on itunes on spotify on
twitter and be like these are the things
i care about i demand blah
and you make a ton of money doing it and
then you're like well i'm not actually
going to do anything about it i question
your integrity thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you